[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández por Andrés
espinal en Ucrania la contraofensiva
continúa en la región de gerson en el
sur del país Qué están haciendo los
soldados nuestros corresponsales
Gulliver crack y ludovit fouca visitaron
visocopilla una ciudad recapturada a
principios de septiembre tras haber sido
ocupada durante seis meses por las
tropas rusas y nos cuentan detalles de
cómo viven los hombres que están
luchando en la guerra
cada día la furgoneta de correos hace
una parada de una hora en el centro de
visocopillas
mamá me envió este tocino casero
Hola
esta es la primera vez en 8 meses que
como comida de mi mamá hay muchos
paquetes para los soldados regalos o
productos comprados por correo Así que
se oye equipo extra lo acabo de recibir
hoy
en visocopilla los soldados descansan
cuando pueden esta unidad se ha
instalado en esta casa hay wifi Pero
estos hombres se quejan de que es tan
mal equipados
Mira las antorchas los generadores
tuvimos que comprar todos nosotros este
año Ucrania está gastando nueve veces
más en equipos no letales para sus
tropas que el año pasado pero todavía no
es suficiente para cubrir todas las
necesidades la chaqueta es un regalo las
botas son otro regalo Es de gente que se
preocupa por Ucrania nos dan nuestros
uniformes
el Ministerio de defensa dice que los
uniformes de invierno están listos y
disponibles estos sombras los están
esperando con impaciencia los haremos
retroceder aún más para que no puedan
volver y los civiles que viven aquí no
tendrán que temer que lleguen a
extranjeros y los desalojen de sus
hogares
la propietaria de esta casa acoge de
buen grado a los soldados durante meses
los rusos ocuparon el lugar
dejaron graffitis en las paredes dibujos
poemas de guerra
toda Europa recuerda nuestros grandes
gritos y contra el ejército ruso no hay
ningún obstáculo
Cómo que no hay ningún obstáculo sí lo
hay un obstáculo para la invasión un
contratiempo un retroceso es lo que yura
y sus hombres han logrado pero quieren
más quieren la victoria
ahora vamos al sur de Ucrania donde
quieefa concentrado una enorme
proporción de tropas para retomar la
ciudad de gerson las fuerzas rusas se
apoderaron de esta estratégica ciudades
del comienzo de la guerra y están
oponiendo resistencia a la ofensiva
ucraniana nuestros reporteros sobre el
terreno han seguido una unidad en la
línea del frente e hicieron imágenes
inéditas que muestran los bombardeos
filmados en tiempo real con la ayuda de
drones un reportaje exclusivo de
Jonathan walsh y amar alhamidawi
estos tanques ucranianos han Librado
varias batallas en los últimos meses
sus movimientos son mecánicos como un
reloj como este t72 de la era soviética
que se llena de munición en cuestión de
minutos
lo seguimos hasta su posición de tiro
junto a su comandante de unidad
la ciudad de gerson está a unos 25
kilómetros de distancia y ha estado bajo
control ruso durante unos 8 meses
nuestro tanque está en su sitio ajusta
su trayectoria y se prepara para
disparar
los Infantería utiliza un dron para
darnos indicaciones
para garantizar la precisión del tanque
la vigilancia aérea se realiza al mismo
tiempo sobre el tanque y las posiciones
rusas objetivo
el ejército aceptó proporcionarnos estas
imágenes una rara oportunidad de mostrar
en tiempo real los puntos de impacto de
los disparos apuntan a una aldea situada
a unos 8 kilómetros de distancia que
está enteramente ocupada por tropas
rusas y pronto es bombardeada por el
tanque que seguimos así como otra
artillería ucraniana
Nuestro objetivo ha sido alcanzado ahora
Tenemos que continuar y terminar el
trabajo
pero el fuego de represalia de la
artillería rusa se acerca nos retiramos
a un pueblo abandonado por seguridad
acabamos de llegar a la carretera que
tenemos que tomar
cerca hay un helicóptero ucraniano que
ataca uno de los objetivos rusos
aprovechamos Una pausa Para volver a la
base de las tropas muchos de estos
hombres estaban defendiendo gerson
incluso cuando Moscú tomó a la ciudad a
finales de febrero y no han dejado de
luchar desde entonces para su comandante
las entregas de armas extranjeras
podrían dar un giro a la batalla
necesitamos tanques modernos abramos
leclerc cheftas británicos con esto
podríamos retomar rápidamente gerson
luego crimea y recuperar nuestras
fronteras desde 2014 y por fin
pondríamos fin a ese genocidio a esa
destrucción de Ucrania una caña estás
tejiendose
A pesar de otras entregas de armas
Ucrania ha estado presionando sin éxito
para conseguir tanques occidentales
desde que comenzó la invasión
la ruta del ron es una carrera
transatlántica en solitario sin
asistencia que se realiza cada cuatro
años y tiene una gran repercusión en
Francia en 2022 celebrará su edición
número 12 previo a la carrera unos dos
millones de personas van a ver los
barcos y a los competidores la regata
está entre los eventos deportivos de
mayor alcance en cobertura mediática en
el país galo después de la Copa Mundial
de fútbol veamos un repaso por los más
de 40 años de este desafío en el
siguiente informe Natalia Ruiz armelé
cooks y flores
se le conoce como la transatlántica de
la libertad cuando se lanzó en 1978 la
ruta de ron estaba abierta a todos los
barcos monocascos multicascos e Moca
fue creada para promover el ron y los
territorios franceses de ultramar sale
del puerto de sambalú y llega a la isla
de Guadalupe en el Caribe en un
recorrido que dura entre 6 a 9 días una
carrera muy francesa que a lo largo de
los años ha cautivado a navegadores
solitarios del mundo entero y a sus
barcos cada vez más sofisticados sus
ganadores se han vuelto legendarios
Michael Burch philippene el dos veces
premiado luego un boño y una mujer flojo
vencedora en 1990 No creo que este sea
un medio de machistas creo que hay
quienes tienen esa imagen pero creo que
es un gremio de marineros donde la gente
se estima por las cualidades no es para
nada Un mundo machista cualidades que se
necesitan para enfrentar Esta carrera en
la que el mar ha cobrado vidas y barcos
en la primera edición manureva
desapareció en las costas de las azores
junto a su tripulante Alan colas
ocho años más tarde el catamarán oyal
naufragó en medio de una tormenta en la
que desapareció para siempre sus keepers
luiwe
ar partirá en este primarán último uno
de los más rápidos y que parece Volar
Sobre el agua el último de la mide 32
metros de largo 23 de ancho y 37 de alto
son los barcos más rápidos normalmente
uno de los nuestros llegará primero a
Guadalupe y pues son barcos difíciles de
maniobrar en solitario porque son muy
grandes y muy potentes Pero son muy
placenteros por la velocidad y podemos
hacer la travesía en prácticamente una
semana
La pasión por la aventura predomina
sobre el riesgo este año un récord de
138 barcos competirán de los cuales 5
serán capitaneados por mujeres el día de
los muertos no solo es protagonista en
México en Guatemala cada primero de
noviembre del país se vuelque en una
fiesta nacional en lugar de catrinas los
guatemaltecos construyen gigantescos
barriletes o enormes cometas que usan
para enviar mensajes a sus difuntos
nuestros corresponsales en Centroamérica
Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
llegaron a Zumpango el municipio donde
la muerte cobra el color en el cielo
en la noche Es cuando ocurre la magia
este grupo de artistas está montando la
estructura que en la mañana sostendrá
las gigantescas cometas de papel de
china que hicieron famoso a Zumpango
este pueblo de Guatemala
y como la armazón es en plena noche y
estamos Pues justo en la luna Bajo la
Luna verdad por eso que alcanza un pan
con Nosotros le llamamos la lunada del
barrilete me ibas a dormir por la
emoción
Juan Pablo se unió a la tradición desde
sus 12 años pero es la primera vez que
participa en la exhibición con su grupo
ahí nomás por qué hacer barriletes pues
cuentan que al momento de que el papel
china cuando uno no eleva choca con el
viento ese sonido que provoca no le
gusta a los malos espíritus después de
desvelarse toda la noche los artistas
reciben la madrugada y a las 200.000
personas que acoge el evento se arreglan
los últimos detalles artísticos y
empieza la demostración para comunicarse
con los muertos vamos una fiesta de
sincretismo católico que se mezcla con
la tradición indígena de Mesoamérica por
las energías de los muertos que que se
han ido
a la hora de nosotros estamos espantando
ahí en el más allá es donde tienen que
pertenecer y no mantener a molestar a
los vivos
esta tradición de de un siglo evolucionó
con la aparición de grupos de artistas
de mujeres los gestos de los expertos
para hacer volar los enormes barriletes
se siguen transmitiendo de manera oral
una herencia cultural que sigue poniendo
por lo alto literalmente la cultura maya
hasta que corresponsales en la semana
nuestro agradecimiento a café de la
tintería por cedernos sus instalaciones
para hacer este programa siga con frases
24 y con Franz 24.com
[Música]